so first of all i remember the very
first one i used to obsess over it and
watch it quite a bit
i love that you guys brought this back i
enjoyed it so much um first of all nev i
know that you said in the first film
that you didn't watch scary movies has
anything changed are you watching siri
movies now
oh sometimes
[Laughter]
not often
um
once in a while i will if i'm coaxed and
they can be really enjoyable i just i'm
so i'm really sensitive yeah i'm like ah
so torturing myself
but they are a fun ride i mean i get the
appeal yeah
how did it feel for all of you guys just
to get back on set um and also when it
wrapped where were you all at
emotionally i know david for you i heard
you you'd cry i heard there was some
tears
well this emotional scene we had to do
it was doing kale being you know on
screen together
and i called for it so it was uh it was
powerful yeah yeah what about for you
guys
oh no i if i feel the same way and also
just we could feel wes's presence and it
was really
you know
the the first scene was my first day the
machine that dewey and i had so just
walking onto the set and knowing we were
starting again so many years later
it was just it was really nostalgic and
sweet yeah they also they rebuilt the
original house
yes that's in this film and
walking onto that thing was really
emotional
because the set designers the builders
they did such an incredible job to a t
it was identical to the house that we
shot in 25 years ago so it was literally
like walking back in time and then you
know one of the characters called wes
and there was a sign inside on the set
when i walked in and it just i know i
burst into tears when i walked in and i
have i was told i think you both had
emotional experiences walking on the set
too
um
yeah i mean these movies mean a lot to
us we have a lot of history around these
films wes was like a father figure in a
lot of ways and just such an incredible
man so um i mean we're so glad to make
them i think wes would be very very
proud that these films are continuing i
think he would be proud of these
directors and this new cast and um happy
that he left this legacy in that it's
carrying on yeah
uh courtney and david did coco get to
come on set like how cool is that to get
to see your parents it was covered so
she couldn't yeah
she was out there she was on like she
was there yeah the whole time but she
didn't get to oh well
there too and they couldn't come
oh but they'll get to watch their
parents be like pretty badass in this
sport we can get her to win she got to
come to one dinner yeah
yeah and she's also
weirdly
not impressed by philadelphia i mean i i
cannot get her to be
starstruck or anything
a long time ago we invited zac efron
over
and that was it she freaked out and i
think she just
either that i don't know what happened
it scarred her for sure
awesome well thank you for your time
guys this is so cool have a good day
thank you take care